[Music]
often professionals want to know if
there is a relationship between two or
more variables for instance is there a
relationship between the grade on the
3rd print exam a student takes and the
grade on the final exam if yes then how
is it related and how strongly
regression can be used here to arrive at
a conclusion this is an example of
bivariate data that is two variables
however statisticians are mostly
interested in multivariate data the
regression analysis is used to predict
the value of one variable the dependent
variable on the basis of other variables
the independent variables in the
simplest form of regression linear
regression you work with one independent
variable the formula for simple linear
regression is shown on the screen
in the next screen we'll look at a few
examples of regression analysis
regression analysis is used in several
situations such as those described on
the screen in example 1 using the data
given on the screen you have to analyze
the relation between the size of a house
and its selling price for a realtor in
example 2 you need to predict the exam
scores of students who study for 7.2
hours with the help of the data shown on
the slide a couple more examples are
given on the screen in example 3 based
on the expected number of customers and
the previous day's data given you need
to predict the number of burgers that
will be sold by KFC outlet in example 4
you have to calculate the life
expectancy for a group of people with
the average length of schooling based on
the data given
let's look at the two main types of
regression analysis simple linear
regression and multiple linear
regression
both of these statistical methods use a
linear equation to model the
relationship between two or more
variables simple linear regression
considers one quantitative and
independent variable X to predict the
other quantitative but dependent
variable y multiple linear regression
considers more than one quantitative and
qualitative a variable to predict a
quantitative and dependent variable Y
we'll look at the two types of analyses
in more detail in the slides that follow
in simple linear regression the
predictions of the explained variable Y
when plotted as a function of the
explanatory variable X from a straight
line the best fitting line is called the
regression line the output of this model
is a function to predict the dependent
variable on the basis of the values of
the independent variable the dependent
variable is continuous and the
independent variable can be continuous
or discrete let's look at the different
kinds of linear and nonlinear analyses
list of linear techniques are simple
method of least squares coefficient of
multiple determination standard error of
the estimate dummy variable and
interaction similarly there are many
nonlinear techniques available such as
polynomial logarithmic square root--
reciprocal and exponential to understand
this model will first look at a few
assumptions the simple linear regression
model depicts the relationship between
one dependent and two or more
independent variables the assumptions
which justify the use of this model are
as follows linear and additive
relationship between the dependent and
independent variables multivariate
normality little or no collinearity in
the data a little or no autocorrelation
in the data homoscedasticity that is
variance of errors same across all
values of X the equation for this model
is shown on the screen a more
descriptive graphical representation of
simple linear regression it's given on
the screen beta naught represents the
slope slope with two variables implies
that one unit changes in
result in a two-unit change and why the
beta1 represents the estimated change in
the average value of y as a result of
one unit change in X epsilon represents
the estimated average value of y when
the value of x is zero this demo will
show the steps to do simple linear
regression in our
in this demo you'll learn how to do
simple linear regression let's use X and
y vectors that we have created in the
previous demo
you
we also insured there exists a
relationship between x and y visually by
plotting a graph
to build a simple linear regression
model let's use the LM function
you
to see how the linear model fits into
X&Y let's plot the linear line by the a
beeline function
let's use the predict function
the linear model we can pass a known
variable to predict the unknown
variables
you
Hey
want to become an expert in Big Data
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos centered up and get
certified in Big Data click here